بعد اكثر من خمسين يوما من القتال في
السودان لحقت باقليم دارفور اضرار عديده
تمثلت في اللجوء والتشريد لعدد كبير من
المواطنين بهذا الغليم حاكم اغليم دارفور
مني اركض اعلن بان اقليم دارفور يحتاجه
لمساعدات عاجله وبان هذه المنطقه من
السودان تعتبر منطقه منكوبه لذلك تحتاج
الى التدخلات العاجله في اقرب وقت
والله بنطالب والناشد المنظمات الانسانيه
والخيريه انها تجينا راجعه زي ما قالوا
تقدمت العون لانه في ناس عانت بجد بالذات
في موسم الخريف ده والوف عندنا في شهر 9
وشهر خمسه واربعه والفصول والغريب دي يعني
في بيكون ركود اقتصادي صعب جدا يعني
المنظمات دي بتسهل مساهمه كبيره لو جاءت
بتساعد في هالمشاكل كثير من البيوت يعني
القتال هو الداير بين الجيش والدعم السريع
خلف نزوحا كبيرا با دارفور فقد تضررت
مراكز ايواء خاصه بالنازحين بغرب دارفور
تضرر معسكر نيفاشا وكساب بشمال دارفور
كمناطق يصعب ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
اليها مع ما تشهده من قتال يومي وانعدام
في السلع الاساسيه وتحول الصراع في بعض
المناطق بهذا الاقليم الى صراع الكل ضد
الكل مما خلف جرائم كثيره جدا وتعتبر
كارثيه بالنسبه للانسان الان المويه
الواحد يمشي بيت في او يجيب سف من الصباح
لحد الازر عشان يجيب برميل بدامواه وينتهي
اليوم الثاني يعني معاناه لدرجه اكثر من
كده وبعدين
الماكل والمشرب في ناس كثير هيكون خارج
اليوم باليوم في سوق والاسواق هما شغاله
والله الاسعار دي مبالغه فيها يعني اسعار
يوميا يعني في اليوم ممكن يزيد حاجه
بمرتين عندك مساله جاز الجاز او الامس ب
350 البرميل